joining us right here back on the rich
eisen show it's been about a month so
it's been too long
uh senior producer at nfl films who is
um
outstanding at evaluating talent as well
as those during the season after looking
at some film
uh he's greg cosell how are you greg
rich
great to be with you and i love what you
said about nfl films since uh
you may not know i'm the longest tenured
employee in the company so i was very
nice to hear what you said you
are i know you are greg and it's the
truth man it's the truth
and i get emotional every time i think
of steve sable every time i hear his
voice as i will tonight
um on the hallmark before the uh before
the thursday night football game
certainly because you know i'm a i'm a
good uh i'm a good teammate so i watch
it on
on nfl network and i just hear his voice
when did you first meet him when did you
i i didn't think it started
this is my 41st season rick so i've been
with
with the nfl for literally 40 of the
nfl's existence
so this is my 41st season at film so i
met steve when i
uh when i interviewed back let's see i
started on july 23rd 1979 so i probably
met him in
may or june of 1979. no kidding
and so what was your first gig there
well back then it was a much smaller
company so for the first
year or so you basically were in
training so you just uh
you know it was a different world
obviously in 1979
um so you were in training for a year or
so and then for my first number of years
i
i worked on we did the game of the week
we had something called the army monday
night game which was about a 10 minute
breakdown of the monday night game that
we did and i worked on those and you
worked all night on those that was sort
of your your uh
your starting point so i'd be up all
sunday night and all monday night
and that's that's kind of how i started
out during my first season well i mean
and were you did you just like walk down
the hallway and there was fasenda in the
break room or something like that or
or well it's funny you mentioned for
sender because i was the last person to
work with john before he passed away we
actually had to go to his house out in
suburban philadelphia
and um he was the greatest guy i don't
know if you ever got a chance to
meet him you're you're a little younger
than i am rich but uh
um he was just an unbelievable guy and
and he would he
about him and if he gave him a great
script he'd always say you gave me a
great horse to ride
[Laughter]
[Music]
i would make that my ringtone if they
you know if
if the generation's actually lined up
technologically that would
you give me i was fortunate to hear that
once or twice so that made me feel
really good because i was young in my
career and he was the master
uh you know because that was back in the
day when local news was different i mean
john fasenda was the walter cronkite of
philadelphia news
right you gave me a great horse to ride
that's
fantastic greg oh man so all right let's
get to the here and now
here um i don't know if it's feasible
for you to answer this but i'll ask it
anyway because the story that came out
of yesterday's show that
so many people are talking about right
now is the answer that lamar jackson
gave me
yesterday when i asked him you know why
are things not coming as easy for you it
doesn't look it's coming as easy for you
and part of his answer was he says that
the defense is calling out
a lot of their plays does that look like
something you're seeing
on film or table well that i certainly
can't speak to because i don't know the
answer to that but here's what i will
tell you
last year was obviously lamar jackson's
first year as a starter and greg roman
and staff
were very creative and innovative in
their run game concepts
they took basic run game concepts rich
and they blocked them
in different and creative ways so what
did teams do
all this off season particularly
division
teams but certainly when the schedule
came out every team that was on the
raven schedule and unfortunately because
the pandemic i bet coaches had even more
time
to do this kind of work so what they do
is they
figure out how to defend this they
figure out
keys they figure out looks they they
figure out the things coaches deal
with on on pretty much a daily basis
and then what you have to do as an
offense is you
then have to adjust yourself and i can
only speak to the film
but i will tell you this based on film
and i've spoken to other people about
this
that right now their pass game which is
something they're going to need to
improve
to get where they want to go their pass
game
is pretty limited and when i say limited
i mean in terms of the past game
concepts
you could even use the word remedial at
this point which is a word that's been
used to me
and clearly the film shows that so i
think
they're at the point where they now need
to to make some adjustments and figure
things out
they'll always have games where they
they do really well because lamar is a
freakish athlete and we know how well he
can run
right and and there are certain things
they can set up
but they're going to have to expand
their pass game to get to where they
want to go
so do you would you view the the
acquisition of dez bryant
being something that the uh coaches
clearly see what you're talking about
too i mean again
john harbaugh's a a coach of the year um
no question on his resume you know what
i mean like it's not like
we're we're probably telling any tales
out of school about what they see
themselves
i'm just wondering if dez is an answer
because any ravens fan out there that
would hear you say this might say then
what is the answer how do you become
less remedial
in the middle of an nfl season well it
also comes down to concepts i mean it's
always good to have
better players no question but i think
it also comes down to what they do in
terms of their past game concepts
because look they drafted marquis brown
a couple years ago and here was the
thought process
the thought process was that teams will
play lamar jackson in the run game
with extra people in the box so that
they will almost always play with
a single high safety and you'll get a
speedster like marquis brown
and on the outside what happens is he
gets one-on-one and he can run by people
and you'll create big plays in the
passing game
we haven't really seen that kind of
offense so it's not just a matter of
getting better players
let's assume dez bryant is at his
absolute best he's a very good receiver
but it's how he is used within the
context of of their offense
so last one for you on this then greg
can you see you've watched enough film
and tape of your entire
existence can you see something we're
like okay it it sure looks like the
defense knew it was coming
or or or sensed it can you can you can
you see something like that
again that's that's hard to answer you
know i would i would just
in some ways reiterate what i said i
think that defenses have a better feel
for the concepts that they're running
and they need an expansion now they need
to build off
their concepts which by the way all good
offenses over time do
you every offense has foundational
concepts it's how you get to them
and that's how you build off of them
that's what really good offense is about
because there's not a thousand concepts
rich you know just like people you know
think that oh there's a thousand past
game concepts no there's not
but it's so it's how you get to them and
how you build off of them
greg cosell senior producer of nfl films
the longest tenure
uh at nfl films joining me right here on
the rich eisen show
what does two of his first two games
tell you
well i thought that this week was just a
phenomenal job by chan galley two is a
certain kind of player
we've i think we've had this
conversation he's incredibly rhythmic
he's got really quick feet on his drop
and set the ball comes out quick
he's got very good ball placement in the
short intermediate area
he's got good movement in terms of
designed movement
uh and i think that what we saw last
week was chan galley
just doing such a good job of playing to
all those strengths
it seemed like almost every throw that
tua made last week he hit that back foot
and the ball came out
so when that happens that means that the
reads are defined
and the throws are defined now that can
happen
every throw every week so that'll be the
next step
but last week it was just it it looked
really good he was incredibly rhythmic
so
so far again looking at what we've seen
it does appear that the coordinator
in miami knows the quarterback
who seems comfortable with the offensive
coordinator
calling what he's calling for him just
that's what it looks like it looks like
there is a match
and that this quarterback who has a ton
of talent and upside
has a coordinator that gets it that's
what you're saying
well maybe i'm old school rich probably
because i'm old you know
right um i think about the eagles lyric
you know half the distance takes me
twice as long that's where i am right
now
but uh i'm a believer in coaching you
know
and and i think that coaching is really
important especially important at the
quarterback position because the reality
is
there's very few transcendent talents at
the quarterback position
mahomes is one of those guys rogers is
but there's not
50 guys with transcendent talent at the
quarterback position
so quarterbacks need to be schemed and
that's not a negative i'm not
that's not saying something bad a lot of
people think that's saying something
bad and you're ripping a quarterback tua
has a particular skill set and a
particular set of traits
those particular traits he has at a high
level
but you have to play to those traits
no there's no question about it because
you know greg we've had conversations on
this show
um and and you could see it in many
other places too i mean it's not just
indicative of here but
um the the number of talented players
who have come out of college
and then there's a merry go round either
at the head coaching spot or the front
office
or the coordinator position and it takes
a forever and a day for somebody to get
in the right spot
and you know miami hasn't been known for
having the right
people in place for the talent that they
have been
ready to have to maybe fill the role of
dan marino
so that's why i'm trying to drill down
here because
you know the the name chan gayley
certainly in dallas
certainly with jets fans that wouldn't
be the guy that you'd say you know we
got to get chan galley uh uh for two you
know we got to get that guy
so that's where i i'm i'm wondering you
know about it
and you're saying essentially so far
this is a match what you're seeing yeah
i think he
he's been doing this a long time yeah i
know i can debate coaches
but he's been doing this a long time and
i think first of all i think
two's traits are evident in other words
i don't think people
struggle to figure out what he is i
think it's very
clear as to what his traits are and what
his skill set is
i don't think you'd get differing
opinions on what he is
now we're going to see him on the same
field albeit not against each other
uh greg costello on the rich eisen show
against justin herbert who looks
phenomenal i'm wondering you going all
22 with this kid
uh we haven't seen the chargers get off
get get rid of the jinx that seems to be
still
uh over this franchise uh certainly at
end of games but
what are you seeing in herbert so far
i've been very very impressed and i was
one guy that that thought that
there might be some issues in him
transitioning to the league early
but i think that he's been very
impressive
and there's a couple of things to me
that really stand out
number one he's a turn it loose
quarterback he is an aggressive thrower
and i always believe in the nfl
to play at a higher level at quarterback
you have to turn it loose now obviously
there's game situations different game
situations dictate throws
but for the most part in the nfl you're
going to have to make throws
and you're gonna have to turn it loose
and you're gonna have to be aggressive
and you're gonna have to make stick
throws into tight windows
and this kid it's in his dna this kid
turns it loose
and i think he's been probably more
accurate than i would have
thought based on his college tape more
consistently accurate
you know he'll miss one or two all
quarterbacks do but for the most part
his ball placement has been pretty
precise
uh and i think that he's thrown and
again this is where coaching comes in
i think he's thrown with a pretty good
sense of timing and anticipation
which is something that did not
necessarily stand out
in his college tape so my guess is he's
been coached extremely well that he's
probably extremely receptive to coaching
but he's and he's again it goes without
saying he's a
very high level talent i mean i've
spoken to some people who think he's
just as if not more talented than trevor
lawrence
and and we know that trevor lawrence is
being spoken about as a generational
talent
so and i'm not one of those people that
talks like that rich because i think you
have to wait till guys play
in the nfl to make those kinds of
statements but he's a highly highly
talented guy
wow i mean that is uh in terms of
evaluating a young quarterback quite a
name to throw out there and i know
uh trevor lawrence is on everyone's mind
in the uh new york metropolitan area i
want to put a pin in that for a second
however
please no no i'm going to go there
though i'm going to go there though
and i want to talk to you about baker
mayfield uh a five and three quarterback
coming off of a bye week kevin stefanski
saying today and i want to get this
quote correctly
quote i think he's ready to ascend what
are you seeing out of mayfield that
might be different
because he's with stefanski in this
offense over the last eight weeks what
are you seeing
another perfect example of coaching
being critical and scheme
helping the quarterback mayfield is a
quarterback that needs
in and this again is not a negative he
needs the system to reign him
in he needs the system to define the
reeds and the throws
for him he needs the system to play to
his strengths
at his best he is
a guy with very good ball placement he's
rhythmic
uh that's the way he played at oklahoma
uh he's got very quick feet he's got a
compact delivery
he needs to play within the structure of
a system
and stefanski system does that it's
highly based on
play action play action boot play action
and play action boot define
reads and throws and you allow your
quarterback
to play that way and that's absolutely
critical so
stefanski is probably seeing that he's
probably seeing him grow
each week uh within the concepts that
they teach
and the key is ball placement when he
had that that great game against
cincinnati a few weeks ago
when the numbers were phenomenal he was
so precise with his ball placement
you know beginning old middle of second
quarter that's the kind of quarterback
he must be
and that's going to be a big game
obviously for cleveland oh so-called
winnable game against houston this week
they could go to six and three
now and let's get to uh i'm gonna unpin
the the trevor lawrence conversation
here greg
um and again i i know look look i'm not
gonna ask you to evaluate trevor
lawrence's an nfl talent i'm gonna flip
it
a little bit right here what because
we've been talking a lot about scheme
fit
and coaches can take a player that uh
that that has yet to blossom
professionally with a ton of talent uh
that if the right scheme right fit is
the is is the
thing that can unlock success for a
player
give me a scheme that fits sam darnold
across the nfl
that as a team might raise their hand
and say let's let's take sam
you know the word talon is thrown around
a lot with quarterbacks
and no one defines what that means rich
you know sam darnold has very poor lower
body mechanics
and he's not consistently accurate okay
so would that if i told you that would
your immediate response be
that makes him a great talent no it
would not
greg but it would also say to me that he
hasn't had the right coaching to tell
him
fix this fix that or he doesn't have the
right confidence level because the
stream doesn't feel
we know that do we know how he's coached
on a daily basis
we're looking at the results right when
we have access to the results
we automatically think we know the
process we don't know the process
we don't know how he's coached every day
we're responding to the fact that
a larger majority thinks that he's a
super talent
and because he's not playing to that
level that it automatically must mean
that he's being coached badly
that that's basically where we stand and
for whatever reason
and i don't get into this stuff you're
on every day so you have to talk about
these kinds of things
for whatever reason adam gase is a
whipping boy
so i don't know how he's coached on a
daily basis none of us do we're not
there
so you but you're not seeing some sort
of maturation for somebody who came in
with uh enough talent to be
a third overall selection in the nfl
draft i think sam darnold to be a good
player
in this league uh needs and again maybe
he's getting this and not responding i
don't know i can't speak to that but i
think he needs hard coaching
i think he needs his mechanics to really
be cleaned up
i think that he needs to be much more
efficient in the pocket
i think there's things that can be
worked these are all correctable by the
way what i'm saying to you yes i'm not
saying that he can't be a good player
all i'm saying is that the assumption
that he himself is great
and that therefore he's being brought
down by everybody around him
we know none of that last one for you
greg
um i'm sure you blanch at the statement
that you hear after a team gets blown
out just throw the tape out just bury
the film
don't look at it i'm sure i'm sure that
i'm sure you're talking about the bucks
now
that's exactly what i'm talking about
what what are you what did you
what's to be gleaned from that boat
racing that we saw
on sunday night well which side of the
ball do you want to talk about let's
talk about the bucks then i guess since
they're they're
they're they're my pick to win the super
bowl pre-season and
what i saw was just so beyond the pale
in terms of
um everything what what
what do you take out of that if you're
tampa
or the rest of the league i guess we'll
start with their defense because i think
there's there's a belief defensively
that
they didn't do what everybody expected
them to do because they'd been a team
that had blitzed a lot
and they played a lot of man coverage
now there's a philosophy
and this is now a philosophy issue
there's a philosophy
from among many coaches because i've
spoken to coaches
that when you play an offense that's
incredibly rhythmic and the ball comes
out of the quarterback's hands really
quickly
as is the case with drew brees there's a
belief that you don't blitz those
quarterbacks because you're wasting a
player that you're not going to get
there
the second point i would make is this
the the saints played a lot at a base
personnel which put the bucks in their
base
personnel defense and most pressure
schemes in the nfl
do not come out of base personnel they
come out of what we call sub meaning
five defensive backs six defensive backs
so the saints knew going in that hey the
ball is going to come out quick with
drew
and we're going to play in base
personnel and we're probably going to
limit and minimize the pressure we get
because
teams don't pressure in those situations
so again it's easy on the outside to say
they should have blitzed
but this is tactical football on the
other side of the ball
i would say that the bucks o-line had a
poor performance
i would say that brady was under a lot
of duress
he it was the cumulative effect of
pressure
every quarterback starts to play faster
when there's
pressure the first play of the game they
they called a play in which they liked
the matchup they put godwin in motion
they got him in the slot versus gardner
johnson on an hour out i'm sure they
loved the match up
and jordan bull rushed the rookie tackle
worse right back into brady
and that sort of set the standard for
the game and they couldn't attack man
coverage
they they couldn't get open versus man
coverage and brady was under constant
duress
see and and and i i love taking the
daily narrative and in shows like this
one as you referred to
uh that moments ago greg and taking the
narrative that we discuss and plug it
into the
hard bitten world of x's and o's and all
22. what about the sense that antonio
brown is just the latest
uh shiny bright shiny fantasy football
object being thrown into the mix in the
middle of a season
of a team that looks like a fantasy team
thrown together
is there a sense that that that's now an
issue too that it's going to take some
time
for this to gel what is the what did the
tape tell you on that front
well you know i thought he looked pretty
good the way he moved they actually
called a shot play to him uh when they
were deep in their own territory i think
it might have been their third
possession
and actually it was a poor throw by
brady brady had a chance to take him
across the field
and give him an opportunity to make a
catch but again brady was under duress
had to move
and then when brady moves he can't throw
the ball deep down the field the way he
used to so
that was an opportunity for a big play
and it didn't come about
but certainly antonio brown i thought he
looked very spry very light on his feet
we'll see how this goes we know that
sometimes when good teams have outings
like this
that they come back and they come back
very strong this is a good football team
with a lot of good players
they're not going to fall apart they
just had a really bad outing both
tactically and individual performance
wise greg you're the best man
let's do this uh let's do this right
around thanksgiving uh right around i
guess the three-quarter postmark and and
revisit all of these subjects
truly appreciate the time rich i really
appreciate it thank you my friend
you got it at greg cosell follow him on
twitter i do
it's a great follow he's a great follow
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that
watch more right here